thank you Ted hundreds of thousands of
new jobs added to the U.S economy last
month but many of those jobs in addition
to another job well as inflation kicks
the cost of everything basically going
up some people in the valley say they're
forced to double up Ryan Matthew joins
us live now from The Newsroom with what
this trend looks like here in the valley
Ryan yeah Christian Kirsten employers
say there's no shortage of jobs out
there that's especially true here in the
entertainment capital of the world but
from Nationwide to locally some workers
are forced to choose between getting by
on one job or maintaining their
Lifestyles with two or more
the job market is bouncing back with
someone that works here no okay thanks
in part to doubling up why have two jobs
at all
uh because America does not allow you to
to live and well with one job it's an
increase that's held steady since the
onset of the pandemic the Bureau of
Labor Statistics visualizes that here
from Friday's employment situation
report that shows 263
000 jobs joining the economy in November
alone in Las Vegas it was nearly 5 000
jobs according to the most recent data
from the Nevada Department of Employment
one full-time and the other one's
part-time but buried at the end of the
federal report shows nearly five percent
of the workforce picking up a second job
Brandon Muse Works security next to the
Westgate Hotel and as of Tuesday now
work security here too I need extra
money everything's going up rents going
up I definitely Googled spots near me
and I just just rapidly applied Elijah
St Louis joining him in security saying
one job pays the bills but not his
lifestyle I like to play games a lot and
it's not a cheap hobby came in kind of
hard you know with the holiday and
others like Kevin Rogers dressed to
impress for his kitchen job interview
after his mechanic work over the
pandemic wasn't cutting it would it be
good to get a consistent job you know
it's bringing in a little bit more money
you know because it's not always
easy working out the back of your trunk
now employers are also looking to retain
these new employees the west gate for
example they've ditched the signing
bonus and are now emphasizing employee
referral bonuses but even so Nevada
still has the second highest
unemployment rate nationwide at 4.6
percent reporting Live From The Newsroom
Ryan Matthey 8 News Now